the Joe Rogan experience they figured
out a way to grow meth with plants they
figured out a way to make meth with
plants this is a new thing they haven't
been able to do this before meth had
always been done with which nothing we
need to talk about sudafed what a good
conversation that is Hren these two when
you go to in California at lycée if you
got a cold and you want to buy some
strong over-the-counter cold meds you
have to give your driver's license and
the reed and they only sell you a little
bit the reason being is because people
used to just buy everything off the
shelf throw it into a basket bring it up
to the counter and they would use that
stuff to make meth with because it's one
of the ingredients right actually boiled
all down on the process but you can make
meth out of cold medication well these
[ __ ] guys have figured out how to do
this [ __ ] with plants now okay so go to
that go to that say okay the plant-based
math is the next frontier of
afghanistan's drug trade so
investigators have uncovered a
burgeoning local trade in the production
of methamphetamine using a mountain
shrub huh see like now let me ask you
this question because I'm a little torn
on this next one put I'm of the belief
that if you like let's say you legalize
lower level uppers or amphetamines okay
so let's say you have a more benign
version of all of these kinds of drugs
that are legal and available we do it's
called adderall
no no but you self go to a doctor get a
prescription for that I'm talking about
over-the-counter right okay so do you
think that because I think that would
not fully eliminate the market for the
much harder stuff but it would I think
eliminate a majority of that market
because if somebody yes right because
somebody goes and gets you know a more
safer alternative that might not be a
strong but you can go get a safer
alternative or get a bunch of a safer
alternative then yeah why wouldn't you
choose that over doing like crocodile
the one that melts off your skin if you
do it for likely like a heroin one
that's like heroin bead ones are the
ones that are interesting because their
productivity drugs and that brings us to
trump let's do it this is so much fun
there's a there's a photograph of him
it's a classic
because it's after I love Mexican yeah
he was talking [ __ ] about you know the
wall and it's all rapists and murderers
that is I think this was Cinco DeMayo if
I remember correctly so easy a taco bowl
and the bowl says I mean he says I love
Hispanics I think and I remember
watching that while looking at that
photograph going since [ __ ] for
real he really tweeted that I love
Hispanics and he's eating a [ __ ] taco
bowl well
the open desk drawer are somebody
focused in on and they realized this is
like years later they realized that it's
all filled with sudafed and sudafed is
again the active ingredient you know one
of the many ingredients in sudafed it's
the active ingredient in meth and so
apparently people take sudafed and if
you take that stuff it gives you like a
little bit of a buzz and if you take
large doses of sudafed it's essentially
like taking like he's micro dosing
dosing meth it's actually a little
deeper than that which makes it even
funnier deep yes because there's a
certain form of sudafed that they sell
in the united states and then there's a
UK version of sudafed and the UK version
of sudafed has that ingredient to it
which is more more of an upper arch kind
of acts like an amphetamine look at this
it says the desk drawer full of sudafed
including boxes in New York perk
purchase on the UK indicate up say that
the legal limits of purchase are being
circumvented and that the then-candidate
Trump was abusing sudafed for its high
rather than its decongestant effect okay
so there's that now I want to take it a
step further because I don't know if you
watched this video I sent you a while
ago but I was absolutely floored by the
contrast between the speech Trump gave
at CPAC this year and then the speech
Trump gave at the UN this year the CPAC
1jo totally off script bouncing off the
walls an hour and 30 minutes hands
moving all over the place so active so
engaging making jokes all this stuff
hilarious and then you go to the UN
speech Joe he's talking like this and
that says and he literally he was so
tired he couldn't even say the word
sovereignty he quit halfway through it
he was like and that's why we need to
protect
yeah and so I if you want to pull that
up Jamie if you want to watch some of
the decent dressed Hackman's show Pakman
had David Pakman had a an episode where
he was concentrating on this alleged
drug use by Trump and he showed the
contrast of him sniffing at the debates
with Hillary Clinton yes we did a yeah
this whole conglomeration of all of his
sniffing moments this and let me just
say in Trump's defense if I was
president I'd be taking some [ __ ] too
because that's a tough job and also
don't lie when he does a rally and he's
high as balls on an upper yeah they're
entertaining oh yeah and I'm the first
one on the left to admit his Twitter
feed I feel bad sometimes because he
genuinely makes me laugh he J I remember
I'll never forget the morning I woke up
and I go on Twitter which is like part
of my morning routine and the first
words I see here from the President of
the United States and it says washed up
psycho Bette Midler and I just saw that
first part of the tweet and I broke down
laughing it was the funniest thing that
makes me laugh all the time he's done a
bunch of [ __ ] on his Twitter that you
just like this [ __ ] is crazy
yeah what was the ones that we were
talking about recently that he did was
it a he tweeted something was [ __ ]
yeah I don't remember what he was saying
was [ __ ] but like that he tweeted
those words was pretty funny yeah yeah
well his Trump isms like the little side
things that he always does makes me
laugh like to all caps randomly yeah or
sometimes they'll capitalize letters for
no reason in the tweet well it was great
when he was the [ __ ] host of The
Apprentice yeah that's when it was great
yeah it was like he was an entertaining
character it's just now that he's the
president it's like whoa whoa whoa this
is real
[Applause]